i was telling robin's story coach when
you were playing when you were a player
you separated your shoulder you went in
the game anyway
and you what you did because you were a
tight end if you had to catch a ball you
would knock it down with your good hand
and kind of push it into your chest and
carry the ball
right well it was similar to that i mean
i i did play where you
had one arm one shoulder strap down but
you played i mean you have a harness on
it where it couldn't move a certain way
it was harder to catch a football
because only one arm went up in the air
right but you could do it you did it but
a lot of guys what about these guys who
sit out when they have an injury the
game's different i mean it's all about
money
right i mean they're going to jeopardize
their career to play one game
and they're earning power and plus you
know it it's just a hard thing for them
to do really
and i don't i'm not sure i blame them i
mean uh i can
i can get my shoulders up but it hurts
you were you were voted i guess like the
number one tight end of all time and all
that
you didn't get a lot of money to play
did you i mean we were kind of
my first contract and no no no that's a
long time ago right we got to put things
in perspective 1961
right i signed a 12 000 contract with a
6 000
signing bonus that's 18 000. but in 61
my dad worked in a steel mill so you
know
but what was his relative but what was
the game plan in life for you in other
words when you're making
12 000 yeah okay that's a lot more money
than your dad was making but still
didn't you worry that you'd get out of
football who knew you were going to be
the great coach who knew what was going
to be
uh what was the game plan it could have
gone horribly wrong right there was no
game plan in my life at all when i
played with the bears
just football my game plan came into
focus when i went to dallas for the
cowboys i played for the cowboys
for four years we won a super bowl i
played for coach landry
i coached there for nine years as an
assistant coach and then i became the
head coach of the bear
so if i would have never went through
that process in dallas i doubt that i
would ever become head coach of the
bears when you were a coach for the
bears
you know i always meant to ask like jim
mcmahon wasn't a great
quarterback in the sense of the all-time
great so you don't need a
great quarterback to win do you you just
need a competent quarterback jim mcmahon
was a winner and a leader
right but if you're talking about
physically he couldn't come close to
moreno
right so so your point of view as a
coach now
is that you give me a guy who's a leader
but he doesn't necessarily have to be
physically the best quarterback that
ever lived who throw the farthest this
and that
you come up with a game plan it's really
a team sport
let me ask you something because i
always wonder what is the importance of
the coach you know like these coaches
now have become
superstars of the game well you know
you're right the players play the game
you know and i said you know
you know somebody once said that there's
no coach worth a player but
i disagree with that i think that you
formulate the game plan everything in
life is a game plan what you do
today you we all have a game plan i go
back in my life to people i've watched
lombardi
right when he went to green bay they
stunk why did they change
right changed because of him and what he
made them understand
there's only one way to do things that
was his way it was the right way he was
a leader and he inspired
right inspiration right he inspired him
you don't motivate they got to motivate
them but also tactically you've got to
be sort of a genius you've got to sit
there and go hey how am i going to get
this ball down for you well the old
thing kis says keep it simple stupid
because it's not
genius it isn't it's beating the other
guy you know what he's doing
you know what you do best but if you're
ever going to give up doing what you do
best to try to defeat the other guy
you're not going to defeat him
after an incredible career in chicago
that you had you'd retire for three
years from
coaching and then you come back and you
go to new orleans
was that a mistake in retrospect i mean
who the hell you got a lot of
aggravation in new orleans right they
gave you crap
not really uh i i tell you what you know
to say why i did it
i thought it was defined intervention
because you got to understand now
i i've been part of two super bowl as an
existing coach and a head coach and then
both of them were played in new orleans
so
i said god's calling me to go to new
orleans unfortunately you mean you
thought you got a sign from god yeah
it turns out god wasn't talking no he
was it's a short it was a short stop
right but anyways no but you hated the
fans there
no i didn't never have no the fan they
listen they're the greatest fans in the
world
they're the most most pers i mean
they've hung in there for 46 years
and what happened in that city last year
with them winning the super bowl was the
greatest thing in the world it was a
great story
katrina the whole thing i mean i was
there through all that stuff it was
crazy